auf den nächsten fall komme ich
überhaupt nicht darauf klar ohne scheiß
und zwar natürlich auch in den usa wo
sonst von congstar wie absteigen ist
schon komisch ist china bereits
willkommen bei einem neuen video immer
wieder auch meine mail kanal und so nach
einer woche oder einer plattform keine
nachricht im urlaub und konnte kein
video machen mein herz rechnung ein
bisschen ich bin ein bisschen erkältet
bisschen krank aber ich habe gerade
vollmer unido zu machen deswegen gibt's
vom video und wie habt ihr bestimmt
schon gelesen habe es geht heute um die
lustigsten beziehungs-aus beziehungs-aus
jetzt keine mehrzahl von beziehungsende
ihr wisst was ich meine
ich habe damals ein bisschen im internet
recherchiert und bin auch ziemlich
kuriose fälle gestoßen
und ja wenn ihr halt so bock habt dass
ich davon mehrfache dass daraus
vielleicht ein kleinformat entwickler
lassen positives feedback schreiben vom
tagebau nach oben ist immer super
freundlich
los geht s also fangen jetzt mal ganz
locker an mit einem typen der
logischerweise aus den usa kam da sind
ja manch ein bisschen crazy und zwar auf
montana oder so montana hannah montana
kommt dass wilhelm und vielleicht man
weiß es nicht der war so krank darauf
der jedermänner aufgestanden ist die
ganze schule von der frau keine ahnung
frauen am ehrenmal so 10 20 paar schuhe
ich habe zwei oder drei und zwar die
genommen und immer mit keine folge mal
von unten und immer an spuren außerhalb
des hauses waren mit kreide wusste er
das haus verlassen das war so der wohl
die halbe überwachen und hatte dann
direkt angerufen blablabla ihr wisst
bescheid ja noch zwei er hat sie das
nicht mehr ausgehalten hat sich getrennt
dann soll das wenigstens zu machen das
ja vielleicht sollen programme in ihr
handy macht dass er weiß wenn sie das
haus verlässt und sie das nicht
mitbekommen dass er dieses programm der
einmal die schuhe an naja usa halt so
lange zweiter mit fall nummer zwei kommt
natürlich auch aus den usa wo er sonst
und zwar wenn man so geizig seine frau
und irgendwie beim unfall ein paar zähne
verloren und konnte nicht mehr sprechen
und wollten gewiss haben ein
vernünftiges gewiss das sollte der mann
halt bezahlen aber an e
er hat dann gesagt nein ich kaufe kein
gebiss du kannst gerne alle zähne haben
die von mir aus fall die kannst du dir
dann einbauen alter wie krank ist das
würde ich mein das musste auch voll
eklig sein du kannst du nicht still oder
ich stelle jetzt folgt eine freundin und
die hätte zähne von mir drin und ich
will küssen mit zunge ii
okay ist irgendwie auch besser als keine
zähne drin zu haben aber man kann doch
einfach sein gebiss kaufen von video auf
den nächsten fall komme ich überhaupt
nicht drauf klar ohne scheiß und zwar
natürlich auch in den usa wo sonst
und zwar ein us bundesstaat vermont den
mann so crazy drauf der hat halt gewusst
seine frau liegt immer v zu hause rum
und schläft oder so keine ahnung wenn er
arbeitet das hat er so aufgeregt dann
hat er sich gedacht kommen ich kaufe
einmal einen papagei und dem papageien
erfolgende worte beigebracht der papagei
konnte gar nichts außer halt immer zum
aufstehen verdammt noch mal aufstehen
also jetzt auf deutsch übersetzt ich
denke beim englischen geld ab [ __ ] you
get up oder so wenig und der kabarett
und wirklich die ganze zeit gerufen geld
ab [ __ ] you get up heißt das überhaupt
so keine ahnung ja und nach drei hat
sich die hier vor danach komme ich hab
kein bock mehr kann man auch verstehen
der letzte fall war auch immer so
richtig behindert und zwar das war
absolut österreich bin mir nicht sicher
aber ich glaube etwa österreich und zwar
war der alten mann der war mit einer
frau zusammen und die wand wirklich
schon 20 jahre alt zusammen und dann
empfiehlt man so plötzlich auch meine
frau hat zugenommen was soll ich machen
dann hat er die ohne scheiß angezeigt
bei einem gericht und wollte also ja ich
liebe nicht mehr sie es alleine daran
schuld und so wollte dann halt verklagen
du kannst doch nicht deine eigene frau
anzeige nur weil sie halt zugenommen hat
ist doch normal dass jemand mal zu einem
bälle nicht mehr 20 soll 41 oder 5
sie ist wenn man halt nicht wirklich so
viel sport macht oder nicht er hätte auf
jeden fall mit dem runde gezeigt die
frau habe seit der hochzeit übermäßig
viel an gewicht zugelegt und das gericht
meinte dann das ist aber halt moment ich
zitiere eine gewichtszunahme zähle zum
gewöhnlichen lebensrisiko ist ja psone
ich wette ich bin in zehn jahren aufhält
nein spaß
ich mache sport hoffentlich macht ein
anderer sport ja heute wie schon gesagt
wirklich mega freuen wenn ihr das feiern
wenn ihr mir doch nach oben da es
ansonsten ab und vergab noch nicht
zuhause nennt sogar vieles eingeblendet
endet mich dafür ja wenn ihr bock hab
halt nur und anderen ständig sagen hier
oben auf der rechten seite von mir aus
gesehen geht's weiter mit mario dass
sein kumpel was bei mir ich an gar nicht
reden ausgelutscht es mag aber egal
checkt das ab und wir sehen uns nächsten
montag wieder auf ihr seid ihr cool
warum auch immer